you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next quarter of an
hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the former press
secretary to Queen Elizabeth Elsa
Anderson and the journalist and
broadcaster Jenny Bond
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
crowning glory is the headline on the
sun on Sunday the paper writing that a
glorious moment of History was captured
The Mirror Has a picture of the king
carrying the orb and scepter
whilst the star leads with the same
picture
from the ceremony
the Sunday Express pictures the king
waving with the headline happy and
glorious
the mail on Sunday has a photo of the
king and queen together on the
Buckingham Palace balcony with the
caption the look that says darling it
was a Triumph
the same image on the front of the
Sunday Times their headline at last
their crowning Glory
the Sunday Telegraph also features a
picture of the royal couple both wearing
crowns from the ceremony
and the Observer also pictures the King
on their front but leads on analysis of
Thursday's local election results
and we are joined tonight by Elsa
Anderson and Jenny bond welcome to both
of you let's start by having a look at
the Observer front page and that uh
photo in which it has to be said the
king doesn't look very happy at all
um no it's uh it's a rather sad picture
in a way but that's just the way his
face sets sometimes I think when he is
as the caption says in a reflective mood
and I think there was there was plenty
of occasions yesterday for him today I
should say actually
um to such a long day and to reflect
about the the gravity of this role he's
taken on I think he feels it really hard
actually there's big responsibility and
he knows it Elsa do you think he was
feeling anxious and and worried and that
the weight of the ceremony was on his
absolutely and also the eyes of the
world are on him but he was in an Abbey
he's a deeply thoughtful spiritual
person and I think he had a lot to
reflect about while he was there so I
don't think yeah I don't know whether it
was so much anxiety but but
thoughtfulness and reflection
that there were moments that were were
quite um poignant in which you felt that
he did relax particularly um I mean
we'll come on to talk about it uh when
uh the Prince of Wales uh kissed him on
the tube but we'll come back to that but
let's have a look at the front of the
Sun newspaper
um and reflecting really on how the the
entire day went I mean obviously there
will have been rehearsals upon
rehearsals and um it would have been
quite nerve-wracking oh I think that's
what everyone is saying you could see
the nerves couldn't you as they stepped
up off the coach and into the Abbey that
I think they were so worried about the
complicated choreography of this uh this
ceremony I mean there was so much that
could go wrong and so much has gone
wrong in past coronations
um and I think it was Robert said I felt
quite sorry for them I think it was
quite an ordeal
I also would add that they always say
never work with children and animals and
of course we had children animals at the
Forefront of the coronation so um that
could be a bit risky as Jenny's pointed
out but you know from my perspective I
just think it was absolutely thoughtless
the whole day and I'm sure when the
doors were closed and the and people had
gone they kicked off their shoes and had
a big sigh of relief I think I think
actually there was probably a different
perspective if you were in the air beat
when we were watching on television
because we had the luxury of all these
close-ups didn't we
um and if they were in there all the
people who were in there said it was
just magnificent uplifting and they just
loved the Splendor of the whole thing so
I think two different ideas there and
also you would only sort of get the
music if you were inside the Abbey and
you know as Jenny said we watched it on
television but you can't get that
atmosphere unless you were actually
sitting in a front row seat
you're talking about working with
animals and children and um that the
grandchildren had a front row Pew didn't
they um Prince Louis disappeared for a
bit I noticed
um but he behaved really well I mean for
a five-year-old extremely long day I
couldn't agree more that I've got two
children I've taken them to weddings
when they've been little and they've
been complete nightmares so golly I mean
how well did those those children behave
on a very very special day yeah he's a
little yawn you completely understood
whereas Charlotte looks as she was
really enjoying it she was giggling they
look very relaxed actually Charlotte and
and his her mum were the most relaxed of
the lot I think whereas George was
looking a bit Whimsical our thoughts
were chewing the side of his mouth and
possibly thinking gosh is this what's in
for me yes I think I caught that that
shot of it when that thought might have
been going across his mind let's have a
look at the telegraph
um front page
love this love this it's the it's the
happy shot isn't it this is how I wished
they'd been able to look throughout but
I mean I don't blame them in the least
it was it was you know a big gig for
them but here they're relaxed it's over
it's done absolutely so that is I think
that they've just come out of the
balcony into the center room which is
the room actually behind the balcony and
that means everything is over and I
think you can see the relief on their
faces and the joy and as Jenny said that
is absolutely the the money shot
yeah there has been some criticism
though on social media of the telegraph
um criticizing that that shot for being
a little bit scruffy
well I just think it's life as it was
that you captured the moment there with
the hustle and bustle going on behind I
much prefer those shots that are less
posed so I beg to differ I totally agree
with Jenny I love it I think it's
absolutely love it I love the chaos in
the background I think they look
wonderful and it's a shot that you know
not anyone has seen before so I think
it's super
let's have a look at the mail
and their their headline which is uh
quite interesting the look that says
darling it was a Triumph
um and that is the the pointer which as
you say that they are much more relaxed
they've got the formalities over with on
Buckingham Palace looking at each other
um it's a great shot that one isn't it
but we don't know who's saying it do we
I we were speculating earlier I did it
means that would be something that
Camilla we were speculating that it
might be I don't think it would have
been would have been the king because
he's very much he's not a man that sort
of blows his own trumpet he'll be much
more saying have I done okay have I have
I been as good as I could be what could
I have done more you know he is her he
is he is the Eeyore to her Tigger more
or less so he would be I think much more
worried about performing in the right
way
and let's talk about
um Queen Camilla's role because there
have been quotes that she's uh said to
friends that she never ever dreamed in
her wildest dreams that she would ever
uh be Queen but it is a reality today
that's the day of Queen Camilla I didn't
think she did think for a moment she
could make this journey and I don't
think she particularly wanted it I
believe her when she said that this was
not a role she ever aspired to I think
she has become I was going to say agreed
to become Queen but she's become his
Queen because she knows he really needs
her at his side she she's the one who
can calm him down support him guide him
listen to him console him
um because as you say he's he's actually
not the most confident of men absolutely
and I think she is the perfect partner
for for him and she will enable him she
will equip him to be the best Monarch he
can possibly be
um and that's what he needs it's a huge
role it
and and he needs that person beside him
to help him do it and I think that's why
the queen decided very very wisely to
say uh last year that when the time came
Camilla should be Queen consort because
I think the queen no knew just how
important it was to have someone at your
side that at the end of the day you can
say well that was a rum I'll do whatever
that's you know there's not a lot a lot
of people they can confide in and so she
has secured that I think we were just
looking at the shots there of when the
the crown was was placed on on her head
and you could see that she wanted to
adjust it herself and kept trying to and
then sort of put her hands down I mean
it it was um an interesting moment
because that is the point at which she
becomes Queen Camilla
um and I guess she wanted to revert to
to her her natural self and and adjust
the crown but really had to remember
actually is something that should be
done by somebody else yeah absolutely
um I think she she did just an
extraordinary job today
um and I think the country was behind
her but I think you're right the the
crowns are pretty pretty unwieldy things
I think we saw that today and it was
almost as if they were walking along
with a pile of books on their head I
must not let it fall what about her
Rehabilitation as it were with the
public
for some people it's it's a journey that
they still haven't taken yes and you do
see that particularly on social media
um you you can tell there's a large body
or I don't know how large it is there's
a body of opinion who will never forgive
Camilla for having been The Third Woman
in uh the marriage
um
I think broadly the public though have
come to respect her and understand that
a lot of people have broken marriages
and now we have you know the mirror
image of so many Blended whatever we're
going to call it extended families in
the land they're a little bit more like
us I think
as let's just talk very quickly about
that poignant moment when the Prince of
Wales kissed his father on the cheek and
actually King Charles said um thank you
thank you William I think the King was
visibly moved by that it was unexpected
it was unexpected to me and I just think
he was deeply moved deeply touched and
it was it
Prince William paying homage to the
Monarch but also to his father I thought
it's terribly touching I was rather
hoping that he might emulate um Edward
VII who was so moved when his son who
became George V did the same that he got
off his throne or his coronation chair
and gave his son a great big hug which
has to be rather lovely
that that would have been something I
would know but it was a very human
moment which I think touched everyone
all the people that you speak to
actually point to that yeah absolutely
Jenny and uh Isla thank you so much for
taking us through the papers of course
we'll do a little bit more
um after
actually we've just got time for one
more the express
um and that um a stunning day of
Splendor and Sacrament let's have a look
at that oh yes that was uh yes they they
really loved it the express they've gone
right over a stunning days Splendor and
Sacrament
um exactly what this this uh event uh
provided for us
um yes it's gone into great it was an
inspiring Showcase of our enduring
greatness full of striking imagery open
symbolism and a heart stirring sounds
beautiful
remind us of the day thank you both